I don't think it's that hard I think all
you have to do with feed them twice a
day I don't know you water them because
that all you do with babies okay
this came so suddenly babies who need
them actually okay whatever sure
technically we like need babies to like
continue Society babies are super
expensive they're very needy they're
mean like sure they're cute and all but
like they're kind of hard to work with
what is it like to be a parent I've
always wanted to be a mom and I just get
the opportunity to have someone and
raise her and love her and pour
everything into her the one thing that
makes me nervous about it it's just like
some of the challenges babies throw
tantrums no Sydney she's 21 so and so
and she's very independent she's really
trying to like find her way around the
world
she can't fully articulate what she
wants a little bit but if when she can't
she cries you know babies will let you
know when something isn't right what do
you think I'm gonna struggle with I
think at the very beginning when I'm
leaving she may wonder where his mom and
she may cry up around that time you know
you take the good with the not-so-great
and you just kind of roll with it
I think the rewards far outweigh the
things that are stressful unique we're
going ready I think so I get to leave
work early so that's a good that's a
place you want job to go to another job
being a dad
[Music]
well any advice before it's not a sprint
it's a marathon alright so we just got
Sydney he's AI Sydney she's Mathers
didn't say hi now but we're gonna get
her in the car seat here she may just
one drop in and sit and just be all like
compliant other time she's gonna like
stand and not want to sit it'll take
some time to get her in there I was
expecting her to be very frantic because
shaniek warned me that there would be
tantrums but it was super easy Sydney
was very docile she is adorable she was
super sweet I put her in the car and
there's no big deal she got in now we're
gonna go grocery shopping okay she
hopped in the car it was super simple we
were walking around we're gonna go
grocery shopping you got yogurt so
shaniek got me this handy-dandy grocery
list city's being very good and this is
so far so good she was a great helper
anytime I handed her an item she would
put it right back in the basket for me
she was like the best you like the
raspbian yes
awesome good job Sydney like the mangoes
yeah won't toss it in
going into this I was like I am NOT a
baby person I think that they are very
difficult but this first hour with City
was amazing I felt like I am the best
dad world and then I tried to put it in
the car after the grocery store and we
had tantrum number one okay so we just
left the grocery store
Sydney it'll be okay she's a little
anxious I think she's ready to eat oh no
wait
did you keep Stan's City okay I know I
know but we have to get in to see she
just started screaming and I couldn't
get her into the car she was kicking to
try to get back like I don't know what
happened
Sydney was just not having you and I was
like we've been together for two hours
and you're already doing the most you
want a snack I had no idea what I was
doing it's very frustrating because they
can't communicate with you so they're
frustrated you can't communicate with
him so you're frustrated this was like
the first challenge where I didn't know
what to do and I was like oh this is
going to be quite the battle we're just
not getting home Sydney qyy can we go
inside
no okay yep this is tantrum too but
it'll be okay it'll be okay Sydney
Sydney we're gonna wash our hands we're
gonna grab some soap
[Music]
[Music]
sit down with Sydney okay enjoy let me
know if you needed things move very
quickly we have a baby toddlers they
okay okay she needs me now here we go
just had a little spill she thank you I
didn't realize how much of a mess babies
would be she just kind of kept putting
her fingers and everything and taking it
off of her plate throwing it on the
ground this is where I'm leaning back on
the meter of like I don't know if kids
are for me getting ready for bed time is
around 7:45 it's hard for me to go to
sleep so I can only imagine a child
I mean it's early when you think about
all the other things you need to do I
mean cuz at this point I've given you a
list I haven't shared anything about you
you haven't even gone to the bathroom
yet by this point it's about 7 o'clock
in Sydney is full of energy she wants to
run around and play games we sat down
and had an adorable moment when we had
tea parties we read books we played with
several different dolls but it was
exhausting they're not letting up at all
Sydney would had so much energy she
would play with the toy for two seconds
run over here jump on a trampoline for
two seconds run into her room and it was
just like she was all over the place by
this point it's 8:30 and I've done
literally nothing for myself so you're
tired she's clearly tired but she
doesn't want to go to bed and it's just
like the most frustrating thing in the
world
all right Sydney ready to get dressed
let's do this wait finally shaniek has
to come help me again to get Sydney into
her bed because she was not having it
but then I still have to clean up the
dishes from Sydney I still have to make
sure her meals were ready for the next
day I still have to get all of her
clothes ready and I'm just like this is
hard
it's so
hard I set an alarm for six o'clock as I
knew listen he usually wakes up between
6:30 and 7:00 I wake up and I don't hear
Sidney crying so I'm like perfect fine
I'm gonna go back to sleep
and I sleep in my second alarm and then
I wake up in Sidney is like ready to go
she's ready for breakfast she's hungry
she's running around she has tons of
energy and I'm like how are we doing
this it's Saturday all I want to do is
be in my bed and it's sleep until 3:00
woke up a little bit late for breakfast
I started to make waffles but didn't
plug in the oven good start we get
Sidney's breakfast together we just cut
up food and like I didn't realize how
much babies eat like City was like going
at it and then she's like more more
strawberries and like you just
constantly have to keep going and keep
thinking ahead we got breakfast started
looks like it's going well
did you drop these plates in the cup and
what why are you doing that one area
that I really enjoyed about being a dad
for a day was getting to pick out
Sydney's outfits I'm thinking like
having her like Northwest I want her to
look like little Blue Ivy like I am
super excited to pick out her clothes
but I didn't think about the weather at
first so I pick out t-shirts and then
she's like no you can't you can't put
her in t-shirt it's gonna be 50 degrees
tomorrow I forgot like weather and
babies have like I don't know
sensitivity to cold okay go to class
City one foot
[Music]
I see you're playing me
I see Cine falls asleep on the way back
from music class and I just pick her up
out of the car seat and we have this
really precious moment oh wait so nap
time for one to two hours great yeah I
get in that you should yeah you should
you think sure yeah because you just
never know you just got to be prepared
don't Bank on something happening
because it's very fluid Sydney is
resting in her tepee look that was the
smoothest transition to bed I think I've
ever seen I think gold star I'm gonna be
quiet so she stays asleep it ended up
being a mistake cuz Sydney wakes up 30
minutes later and she's like ready to
eat me she's like where's my you said we
woke up from a nap and they're gonna
have a little lunch made a little mini
nap so we're gonna have to take another
longer nap after this are you okay for
nap time after this know you're busy
eating I don't know why I'm talking
about eating with Sydney's always an
adventure Oliver who ended up either on
her body or on the floor where I hang
out with sitting a little bit and I keep
trying to get her to go back down for a
nap
I once sitting it out so I can that but
she's not giving me any type of a break
and since she didn't want to go to nap
we just went to the park described my
favorite part hanging out with the
toddler for 24 hours you really could
see how they see the world it was little
moments like that it started to sit in
like in the last couple of hours where I
was like this is the fun part of it
being a parent is that you get to kind
of relive your childhood through someone
else and you get to see how smart and
talented and cool your toddler is a
person
whoa there are times where things will
be easy and fun and there are times when
things will be a bit challenging you
take the good with the not-so-great and
you just kind of roll with it
I think the rewards far outweigh the
things that are stressful there we go
this is so much easier the last time
this is a major improvement I'm not that
much of a planner so it's really hard to
deal with a kid who just completely
needs you and you have to think about
all the things they need on top of all
the things you need it made me
appreciate growing up so much and all
the sacrifices my mom made for me it's a
tough job and there a lot of you out
there who want to do it I just don't
have anyone
[Music]